con la primera luz del día inicia el
camino hacia el norte son cientos de
migrantes muchos de ellos venezolanos
que con pocas bolsas y maletas a sus
espaldas emprenden la búsqueda por el
llamado sueño americano No importa que
tengan que sortear caminos pantanosos
Ríos o montañas cruzar la selva es un
sacrificio necesario en su camino por
una vida mejor este
viaje lo primordial es que Dios nos dé
salud No de fuerza y llega a Panamá
estos Caminantes que recogen los pasos
de otros miles que han cruzado por el
Darién señalan que la situación política
de su país los ha impulsado hacia la
selva pero el paso por el Darién es una
misión letal Keyla Pérez es venezolana Y
actualmente se encuentra en Costa Rica
La travesía entre la frontera Colombo
panameña casi Le cuesta la vida a su
hija hay personas que se pierden hay
personas que no aparecen más tú por tú
vas caminando y te consigues restos de
humanos gusanos hay mucho excremento
humano
mi hija mi hija agarró esta bacteria en
la selva agarramos está esta bacteria
sin embargo este solo el primer paso en
un largo viaje hacia Estados Unidos
según el alto comisionado para los
refugiados de la ONU acnur más de 7
millones de venezolanos abandonaron su
país debido a la grave crisis económica
social el flujo migratorio golpea con
fuerza los países de tránsito como
México donde varios migrantes se quedan
varados en la frontera norte Estados
Unidos por su parte anunció un acuerdo
binacional con México para recibir a
24.000 migrantes venezolanos bajo
ciertos requisitos una medida que no es
suficiente para la magnitud de la crisis
migratoria